Transcriber: baraa sohaib
المدقّق: omar idmassaoud
بدأت الحكاية مع أول زيارة لي لمركز لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصة.
لم أكن اعرف عنهم شيئا
حتى بدأت الاستماع والقراءة
عن المشكلات التي يواجهونها في حياتهم،
سواء كانت حياتهم العملية أو الاجتماعية
أو حتى المشكلات التي تواجه أسرهم.
والذي ساعدني في ذلك هو أن والدتي
تعمل في مركز لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة،
مما أتاح لي فرص كثيرة لزيارة المركز
والتكلم مع الأطفال،
فاكتسبت من الأولاد معلومات أكثر
مما كنت سأكتسبه من الأنترنت.
بما أنني كنت مهتمة بهذا الموضوع فقد طلبت
زيارة مركز لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة،
وهذه كانت أول زيارة لي
لمركز لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة.
كانت تجربة جديدة بالنسبة لي.
لفت انتباهي أمور كثيرة.
أول ما لفت انتباهي هو أن الأساتذة
كانوا يشيرون إلى طلابهم بكلمة “ابني”.
مثلاً ابني عمل هذا أو ابني عمل ذلك.
في أي مركز لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة هنالك
مُدَرِسة مسؤولة عن عدد محدد من الأطفال،
وهذا العدد يتراوح
بين واحد إلى ثلاثة أطفال.
هذه الكلمة “ابني” كانت تحسس الطفل بالراحة
والاطمئنان للمُدَرِسة المسؤولة عنه.
وهذا الشعور هو أهم شيء.
ما لاحظته ثانياً هو بعض السلوكيات
المختلفة عند الأطفال،
مثل نوبات الغضب حيث أنهم يصيحون ويصرخون
ويضربون الأرض بأقدامهم.
ومن المواقف التي شهدتها وكدلالة على ذلك
كانت هنالك بنت صغيرة مصابة بالتوحد
في يوم من [غير مسموع]
كانت عطشانة فأعطيتها قنينة ماء.
عندما أمسكت قنينة الماء بدأت تصرخ هستيرياً
ولم تتوقف عن الصراخ
إلا بعد إزالة الغلاف الموجود على القنينة.
فيما بعد تبين أن سبب الصراخ
هو أن هذه القنينة لم تكن قنينتها المعتادة
وكان هذا تغييراً في روتين الطفلة
الأمر الذي ضايقها.
موقف آخر: هنالك ولد من الضروري بالنسبة له
أن يحضر إلى المركز في الساعة 11 تماما،
ولو جاء متأخراً ولو عشر دقائق
فستكون مشكلة،
ويبدأ بالصراخ كما في الحالة السابقة.
الفكرة هي أنه عندما يتغير الروتين
يولد ذلك نوبات الغضب.
كنت أيضاً مهتمة لمعرفة المشاكل
التي تواجه الأهل،
وإحدى هذه المشاكل هي الإنكار.
كانت هناك امرأة تشتكي من زوجها لرفضه أن
يقوم بواجبه تجاه ابنه من ذوي الاحتياجات.
حتى في أبسط الأشياء كأن يذهبون للتسوق
أو المشي معا فكان زوجها يرفض القيام بذلك.
وعندما سألته زوجته عن السبب قال أنه خائف
من نظرة الناس إليه لان هذا الولد هو ابنه،
وكان خائاف من أن يقع في موقف مع ابنه من
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة ولا يعرف كيف يتصرف.
لو توقفنا هنا سوف نجد أن اللوم يقع على بعض
الناس الذين ينظرون إلى ذوي الاحتياجات
بنظرة التنمر والسخرية أو نظرة الشفقة
وهذه النظرة كانت السبب في شعور الأب
بأن مرض ابنه شيء يدعو إلى
الخوف من نظرة الناس إليه.
بعض الفئات يواجهون صعوبات
من زملائهم في المدارس
كأن يتنمروا عليهم أو يبتعدوا عنهم
ولا يلعبون معهم.
كما أن بعض الأمهات ترفضن أن يختلط
أبنائهم مع ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
على الرغم من تحقيقهم معدلات جيدة في أشياء
معينة كالفنون أو الرياضة وخاصة السباحة.
موقف آخر حصل في المركز الذي كنت أرتاده
حيث قابلت ولدا
كان يستخدم هاتف معلمته بينما ينتظر أمه.
عندما اقتربت منه وجدت أنه
كان يحل مسائل حسابية بسرعة عالية.
كان ينتقل من مستوى إلى آخر بدقائق قليلة
وعندما سألت مدرسته عن ذلك قالت:
أن هذا الولد ينتمي إلى فئة معينة وهي
التوحد عالي الأداء
وهو أن بعض الأولاد المصابين بالتوحد
يكون لديهم مهارات معينة
كالرياضيات أو الفن أو الموسيقى.
هنالك فئة معينة من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
لو وفرنا لهم البيئة المناسبة
وتعاملنا معهم بطريقة صحيحة فسوف يندمجون
ويتكيفون مع المجتمع
وسنحصل على نتائج جيدة.
كما فعل مطعم ماكدونالدز
حيث اهتم هذا المطعم على مدار الخمس
سنوات الفائتة
بدعم مرضى التوحد وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
بشكل عام عن طريق عدة أشياء.
من هذه الأشياء انهم يستخدمون الضوء الأزرق
في اليوم العالمي للتوحد الثاني من أبريل.
كذلك فتحوا باب التدريب لذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصة بمشاركة الجمعية المصرية للتوحد.
عندما اتصلت بإدارة المطعم
للحصول على معلومات عن التدريب
أخبروني عن بعض المشاكل.
أولا يعتمد معظم المتدربين على نظام معين
للحصول على التوجيه والدعم بشكل مستمر.
ثانياً من السهل أن يتشتتوا بسبب الزحمة.
لذلك راعى ماكدونالدز هذه الأشياء في اختيار
الأماكن لفتح باب التدريب
اختار مكانا كثافته المرورية قليلة
بالإضافة إلى مراعات وقت التدريب حيث تكون
أربعة ساعات عمل و30 دقيقة استراحة،
لكي يحافظوا على تركيزهم.
وكذلك تساءلت عن ردة فعل الزبائن
على هذه التجربة
فكان رد الفعل على المبادرة
بعد إعلانهم على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
دعم كبير من الناس وأسئلة عن أماكن التدريب
ليذهبوا ويقدموا الدعم إلى الأولاد بأنفسهم.
وكان لذلك التدريب والدعم
أثر إيجابي على هؤلاء الأولاد
حيث وجد أهل المتدربين أن أبناءهم
قد ازدادت ثقتهم بأنفسهم.
أتمنى أن تدعم أماكن أخرى ذوي الاحتياجات
كما فعل ماكدونالدز وتعطيهم فرصة للعمل.
من خلال تجربتي مع ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
أنصح جميع الناس
أن يقوموا بزيارات اطلاعية للأولاد والمراكز
وأن يدعموهم ويدعموا
أهلهم لأنهم اجتماعيون ولطفاء جداً
وليس كما نتصورهم أو يقدمهم الإعلام.
على العكس هم لطفاء جدا
ولقد أحببت التعامل معهم.
في النهاية شكراً لكل أب أو أم تحملوا
المسؤولية بأكملها في غياب الطرف الثاني.
وشكراً لكل أب وأم
اهتموا بقدرات أبنائهم ونموها
وقدرات أبنائهم من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة
ونموها وأخرجوا شخصاً مفيداً للمجتمع.